what's up rambla dels yeah I apologize I
really got to make this rant bleed oh
this thing happened I don't know why
thanks for lizardom you got another
episode coming up
CJ Sullivan good friend hilarious guy we
talk some sports old-school Chicago
comedy [ __ ] it's uh it's a fun time you
may have noticed so you may have heard
the podcast is moving to luminary very
soon so gonna get luminary for more info
on that a lot of other great creators
also joining a luminary March 23rd Kent
Washington I'll be there doing a gig
check that out on the website it'll be a
fun time and
[Music]
yeah one dunk I'm thinking about for my
latest fitness day mm-hmm gymnastics
adult gymnastics adult Jim - can see the
backflip for Duncan
I think what's easier to attain a
backflip with Duncan backflip probably
right of course I start with tumbling
just basic training yeah yeah and then
the rings and then the ring you want to
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we go on all school hey what's up CJ so
helping sculpt it in a beaten sage a
sculpt and Sullivan I can't believe you
make money doing this either I with you
I agree well yeah that's a beautiful
house it was great how I don't Tony
traffic Hey yeah we'll go to boy um but
boy and upbeats they got a great
sandwiches yeah
Anthony Rizzo Oh Anthony Rizzo family
all blame them beef over fifty years of
good baptized sandwiches is it
baptized it to the to the folks at home
to the folks listening in that don't
understand what that means
CJ will you explain what that means when
you get an Italian beef sandwich and you
baptize it
that means you dip it in you I bury it
in the sauce and make it you make the
juice
yeah and jus use yo juice whoo that's a
sweet beef mmm sweet babe sweet smell
beef that's gonna be Tony's sideshow
yeah that's called I
I smell beef and it's just gonna be a
half an hour show of just beef like you
I invite guests on and if they got beef
it's assumed yet beef he's like he
stalks me to go so you see oh my god I
see him a couple times boy you got beef
yeah yeah baby I'll talk to my beef with
that he wanted seven see him in a while
yeah bass and I just keep pride just
keep it rotten until I find beef and
then at the end of the show I either
figure out if it's hot beef or sweet
beef he settles the beef not me I don't
settle the beef I just judged the beef
is it sweet beef or is it hot beef is it
sustainable beef is a sustainer is a
locally grown beef or do this leave come
from overseas so I smell beef that's
gone that's mom that's my new show idea
okay yeah what what's the is it's
produced by Hannibal Burres wait whoa
whoa I smell beef here I'm not on board
with this I haven't sold executive
producer Hannibal Burres
[Music]
season was how we doing yeah yeah just
coming to town I love it will be part of
the Rambler big fan we've been wanting
to get you on your forever we love you
CJ Chicago Chicago knit well I know
Coghlan by how many times can you have
Bozeman on for Christ I get a chance
look at Mike hot beef heart beef C
Campbell I think your keys I think your
uh I think you your keys are better now
[Music]
see this visual is exactly how it
exactly how it sounds when you listen to
it yeah trim getting into it hand was
smiling I haven't look at hitting like
you got a vibe everybody I'm sure right
that's my one thing about watching when
I watch a band jazz band any type of
band everybody have their own there's
like face in their own way and some
people they think you know I probably
think like when you play me you probably
think you look cool but you don't but
you just feel it amusing as I've been
the orgasm face yeah did you play an
instrument for separate ones in grade
school um I played piano growing up a
little bit not good now I guess not
really cliche harmonica on the original
sleep apnea machine yeah any fact I've
just placed Immokalee save it play
harmonica breathe into it and Jess I
could played out a bit but no but the
answer not and I can't play this I
certainly can't play with it meaning
what
yes you can man come on man get in there
yeah yeah so nice
that's a beautiful staple for so that
was the reset nap you just yeah right
[Music]
well you've been up to this week
we this weekend well uh just listen to
some Ramblers basically I've listened to
John Haim I'm so right for a guy yeah no
Tony Trent was definitely the star of
that episode you guys we talking normal
conversation and then uh she would come
in
yeah gosh clever Rob nice [ __ ] nice
you tried to kill me larry's he's like
yeah I don't know it was all right I
guess it wasn't really my thing
ah Matt dice anyway yeah you said are
barely your singing you sing me yeah
back in the day you all gave me some of
my first radio podcast visitors locker
Roach we just restarted actually yeah
that was genuine excitement it's a rare
occasion when you got a phone call from
Hannibal or genuine excitement it was
twice in one day
you started back off Leonard uh mean
Nate's Craig started out here and okay
and we did episode flannery in Chicago
last week and he's been involved so you
asked me me Flannery 9 that Craig yeah
we've all gotten like a couple episodes
so far were student videos cooking it up
yeah we're getting it all together yeah
what he's talking about is business
Locker and was an old podcast years ago
in Chicago kind of podcast
it was live internet radio we don't know
what we were doing I was like we should
do like fire like a fire narrative she
did five days we used to fight this week
that was coming back like four yeah and
it was uh yeah there's wait I mean this
is this is definitely way back back when
who's that oh five you started I
couldn't Marin was still on coke I mean
this
fathers yeah you know what I mean yeah
yeah you're on many time bottles we've
Laurent I was it out there and yeah it
was the Sports Talk comedy kind of show
started explain comedians and personname
sportscasters not the other way around
was our tag phrase yeah I needed a tag
and yeah it was mean name Craig the
legendary Pat price Shawn Cole was there
for like a month then he went crazy
moved out in the woods
yeah then Shawn Flannery when was going
when I was really cooking those be flan
terrain and Bryce and Pat price passing
it was funny we actually we uh we were
gonna do what we came out here to do a
thing for serious radio they wanted
whatever I wanted to do a station and do
a show and then well they they had their
they gave you some I wasn't in the
contract but everybody goes to show on
here and then Pat Bryce passed away so
they wanted to come out and see if we
could do it without I me and Sean you
know so we came out here and we and we
did it we thought it was great
you know our shows we have fake callers
and like I said we do I'm like we
thought we'd nailed it were like [ __ ]
flying around the talent we just came
back with all these notes like yeah you
didn't you didn't you only took two
callers okay we don't want callers like
we have to you know that's how we know
ratings about people you have to give
them open questions and like hear from
the I'm like we don't I don't want other
people being on the show at all I guess
that's not that's all pointed show you
know like and yeah this gave us all
these notes and we were above notes back
then because we were 25 yeah so yeah we
did not get that and then we came with
that Chicago I'm just kept dome so it's
here but it's coming back this is lack
room look that up
well Flannery's in Chicago any yes sorry
but you guys but now the Skype as you
know how'd you guys live in Chicago you
can do this from anywhere yeah you know
anything anywhere that's why I just
moved up to LA
ten years too late ten years ahead of my
time what
what was that you did you did a show
it's a flyer up at north bar yep Chicago
cautionary tale constantly retail yeah I
left Chicago too late or was it
cautionary tale
yes the room I think was the remains the
lines done left behind
yeah people who never left Chicago yep
he had me we had a mark year he actually
did a set for the first time in a while
Adam crushes crime for trafficking that
I'm in Saints which is great Wow yeah
it's good back to supports real and we
invited a bunch of young comics into
with the watch all right to learn like
do not become these poor you know these
shells of horrible yes at least you know
at least a quick year right to reset
mm-hmm Chicago is like that as much as a
cago likes hometown they like yeah you
can't unless it like you get you get an
anomaly once in a while you got a chance
the rapper who can who could stay and
still do it but rap game is different
right comedy game acting game you know
is you gotta leave yeah and come back
together and why is that I don't know
music is just because the music business
I mean obviously musicians move to a
rappers move to LA New York Atlanta but
music because it goes everywhere you can
blow up you can blow up nationally or
globally with music you can be in Little
Rock well you could be anywhere and have
your music well hop off you know yeah I
mean I guess now with the internet and
social media in comedy you can kind of
grow that that audience from anywhere
but what I wanted to ask because I
what's your favorite sports talk radio
segment
I got an example what you're talking
about
who you crafted I've listened to so much
crap in the last two weeks
hey Matty you know you hear all that
crap I understood that crap was gonna
come with the territory I feel very good
right Bernstein I forget who it was yeah
yeah but yes I Maya Collin and who you
crapping and it was another one I gotta
think of it is another catchphrase one
in Chicago that was uh it was it was
everybody was pretty it was good like
[ __ ] like that
you got any ones like that smoked beef
what's that
do you smell the beef I know won't see
it's funny cuz like all the shows like
they on TV now like first taking [ __ ]
like that all debate shows especially
back when was like skip bayless League
that's all it was a sports talk radio on
TV it's on the baton like any suisse
always make fun of it because like how
could you be that passionate about every
subject that comes every sub like you're
yes I'm no you know and how can you
really be that passion about every
[ __ ] about everyone every story that
comes up on the day like you're really
that into you know the Baseball Hall of
Fame right now or whatever whatever at
that yeah so we should do seven we
debated against each other and then we'd
flip it around mid argument and then
like we just take the opposite if you
don't care you know I'll be under sent
behind anything when we crap it was a
good title of a segment for for you
Chicago boys and parenting listeners
that's what that was from I guess it is
free I mean even though you have to see
a lot of that stuff on sports TV is is
BS been there filling time but I guess
there is a talent to be a course oh yeah
five minutes on us crying Scalabrine
sweet whoa
Scalabrine twit up for that long that's
good no he shouldn't have tweet and to
care about it forced to care but
sometimes I could tell you I love being
able to tell when they're obviously
phoning it right
you could tell kind of skip man as it's
phoning it in or just sometimes you can
see when he's dead panning it yeah he
used to have more energy sure but now
he's he's so paid he probably I see he
probably I said those surreal moments
like people really still buying this
like yeah I mean like what a world I
created myself how do six million a year
to say LeBron sucks you know anyone the
right mind obviously knows I always find
something negative to say about LeBron a
crazy that's that's how huge LeBron is
is that there's a guy that's a
millionaire just was saying [ __ ]
about the grind
that's how much money falls off LeBron
it's written down in fact there's haters
are rich Wow damn LeBron also flying
right now because obviously he's there
in our ladies you know everyone's talked
about and he's like you know he's like
this god no one says anything bad about
I'm suffering skip bayless you know with
this he open up that school which is
amazing then today there was a what is
Gibson I didn't see what skip said about
the school lunch lines were big was a
wheelchair-accessible one of them today
there was a video on have you seen it
LeBron was given a pep rally and I
pepper like a pep speech to his son's
basketball team right no one stopped him
how great it was he's young and he's it
was good whatever has a nice speech for
everybody's talking about like you know
whatever your role is that's we gotta do
it's a team sport if you're on the bench
egos people arm a bench are still great
players there's people in the NBA NBA
bench you can say they're scrubs now
learn even better some of the best
basketball players world but
knew the role we announced on the bench
players you don't want to do that you
know go play golf or tennis an
individual sport you know team sports
you gotta sacrifice I'm just talking
about 12 year old kids right listen if
you're on the bench as a 12 year old
you're our scrub okay yeah you're not
making a [ __ ] league yeah no you're
right the guy on the bench in the NBA is
a great basketball player scoring forty
five is a twelve year old he's
struggling with his now he accepts his
role yeah it's begrudgingly and through
gritted teeth it's just also depends on
the coach or the situation and go from
being somebody you know you see it
having the stars and people that used to
drive 2325 a game I'm out and all of a
sudden getting do netplay did not play
coach's decision which is right that's a
tough thing that's got to be a tough
thing to see on a box score that seems a
turn at play it's so finally is decision
healthy scratch but um that is a
downfall almost where like Carmelo right
now like he always said he refused to
come off the bench much I think he's
gonna start for Houston now but because
they don't have a rose gone for no
reason they let him go to usually could
have paid him but I like it like what
now and Ireson would refuse come off the
bench but maybe you know what surely
I'll rather go to Turkey and start and
that's we didn't [ __ ] like turkey
that caught the bench in Memphis [ __ ]
this Isaiah Thomas on the same [ __ ] to
rain he won't play off the bench right
why's that yeah where is he out right
now
I have no idea no he was saying that he
or I can seem say that la I would if I
might say Thomas I'm not coming off the
light I'm not come off the Lakers bench
to let I thought I whose must wrong he
said this was a while ago - I think he
said one thing about Isaiah Thomas from
the eighties
[Music]
you know what you said Trevor read they
didn't sign them for no reason right but
maybe there is some internal reason way
like you know he said some weird [ __ ]
there's a party because it's a job just
like right just office job so some of
that little [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna be that
patty cuz I mean in sports you can you
know disparage your boss publicly it
still if you ballin out you get
reassigned you know I just like to think
of the Rockets as a team and an actual
office Christmas party got too drunk
yeah Xeroxes ass or hit on the owner's
wife some weird [ __ ] oh he's just
something he said as a joke got
misconstrued on a beam by the bow you
not resigned
[Music]
I can see Chris Paul's and he's gotta go
him not taking a joke - well Chris
Paul's pretty serious person DeAndre
Jordan needs to put the ball back on
right yeah a very small person even
though he's taller than me six six three
or something 6-1 6-1 or 6-2 is some like
that right yeah those NBA short guys are
not sure in this it's funny to make fun
of or Muggsy Bogues yeah the 5-footers
that's crazy he was five three Mugsy
yeah how's that he listed five three no
he's really full of spud Webb he was
five seven that's great oh boy kids five
five Nate Robinson five seven
how could you physically play basketball
again five nine these giants with your
five three how's that even possible
I'll burn you don't box out you just
thought you figure out other ways you
know what do you do next you don't be a
sociopath Ivana comes your own wife you
just have to be incredibly athletic and
angry I get angry about when I want to
use them as examples like see it's not
the size of the dog you know whatever
it's all gonna finally let you touch
Matt if as long as you work hard enough
you know doesn't matter how big you are
you can make an elite yeah yeah he can
make in the league one other there's a
lot of 5 foot 5 people out there I mean
yeah he could be he's an excellent spud
Webb didn't he like win a dunk
championship you might just fainted of
course famous that's
that's even that's just a step further
that is also and you he was great and he
was also when he'd done he kind of got
of course like people couldn't believe
he was dunking holy [ __ ] get like
Dominique's don't like 720s moving [ __ ]
[ __ ] jump double as height they just
they don't want to hand them don't come
excitement yeah I can't compare that to
improv people laugh at him probably he's
making it up on the spot
you got you got beef with improv people
spud Webb and improv improv a lot of
comedians I don't know it's the worst
have robbed people is it's a made-up
beef yeah no it's not made-up beef
favors everybody Lane based upon SNL
right in game now means the beef talk
about late Wow gotcha nevermind it's
more prevalent Chicago it's nowhere else
cuz I'm probably in Chicago I think I'm
gonna tell you about your puck I don't
get in this conversation any subject you
guys brought up you know ramble on to
the next one no shrim
not this one you like Pinterest sculpin
this isn't actually this is my first
time on a handsome Ram when I was uh
yeah I did a brief like eight second
cameo Babylon where the background yes
off I came in I dropped a Emmanuel Lewis
joke and then I made fun of trim because
you could you cut that get open mic what
about Patricia Patricia in a Pinterest
what about Pinterest do you do Pinterest
you know I have a Pinterest yeah but I
feel like I don't know like the
Pinterest is is a is mostly women's
[Laughter]
using the kiddie table last time I was a
year ago
I wonder about you know spud Webb in the
80s of these players did you tell girls
that you're in the NBA right and not you
know super basketball fans [ __ ] up
get at it yeah yeah I'm in the NBA yeah
run along Mugsy yeah go go do what you
do in your fantasy world you're [ __ ]
five great son of a pull out your NBA ID
card it's clearly a fake look at look at
my Players Association look at my
basketball card yeah anywhere Dominique
Dominique Wilkins come over and tell her
that moiety tree Rollins and mugs and
spud tree and spud would have made a
good duo I think in 80s at last bit of
Atlanta scene yeah I think is you're
getting on your way there you stop
drinking your best shape I've seen you
in
thanks man put some calf shoes on you
get those those lifts over there I think
I would think about these arm out on a
regulation room
regulations what nevermind it's never
gonna happen every night so way on the
other side of 30 if you wanted a chance
I don't I don't think it's impossible
I'm thinking about for my latest fitness
day mm-hmm gymnastics adult gymnastics
adult jim nash can see the backflip for
Duncan
I think what's easier to attain a
backflip for Duncan backflip probably
right
of course yeah yeah absolutely I start
with tumbling just basic training yeah
yeah and then the rings and then the
ring you want to I felt the shock in
your hands out the judge watching up
Russian I've always wanted a goat I've
always wanted to be able to well not
like try to but the the man if you could
kill it on the parallel bars imagine
that how exhilarating that feeling must
be to just [ __ ] hop from bar to bar
and doodle spins and then [ __ ] you
know flip off it and land perfectly on
your feet that's like almost like
superhuman mutant powers man like that's
just
unforeseen ball like I can't I feel like
even if I started doing that at five
years old I wouldn't have been able to
just I think you could only start a five
but you have to start a five I mean
that's like too lately those gymnasts
like they go little you look like three
years old of training don't you that's
where they're all they're all like a
rift but they're all like stunted yeah
yeah and then all the wrestlers I
remember I had the cauliflower ears in
high school what I do like about
gymnastics though like because you know
we watch it every once every four years
in the Olympics you know that like you
know skating is like the only time I
watch some college didn't it yeah yeah
so any off-season absolutely bothers
gymnastics college football
volleyball I'll take it to the next
level i watch with my phone and I look
up their Instagram accounts I watch
college gymnastics look at the Instagram
accounts go to the Instagram accounts
see if they follow broad city or a lot
of glass ha ha yeah if I'm a sports
anymore here's a question
you guys both dabble in some sports
gambling right yeah so like do you guys
do that like get that deep into the into
the research where you just you find
their Instagram account and then try to
see what they did last night like Oh bud
Webb was [ __ ] at blah blah blahs
birthday party he was clearly getting
smashed he's not having a good game I'm
betting against though you guys over
here go that denotes you know no I mean
plans don't usually post up right the
winner dieta some you might hear a story
about them being out there hazel-e right
there used to be a legendary stat where
Knicks games in Atlanta speaking Elana's
in Atlanta eccentric show Knicks games
that come Sunday afternoons or say any
time they're the Knicks were in Atlanta
Patrick Ewing will get worked over those
Atlanta strip clubs they were taking
that like deep so you can always fade
the Knicks yeah they were good in
Atlanta but actually you know they where
the underground was at the underground
strip clubs back because they're pretty
uh the Atlanta strip clothes are pretty
Magic City yes so you would indulge and
not have a game ok but no it's not like
that it's not like this like the 50s
were some oh you got his girlfriend
knocked up family like Robert De Niro
and cuz casino remember he had like all
the inside right yeah but at that point
a little bit this year I don't know if
it was I don't know if there was it was
because of partying but a lot of teams
that play the Vegas go nights in Vegas
Vegas was really good at home so I don't
know if that's because players were
going out also hockey players aren't
that famous so rap they are able to go
out without really good they called the
Vegas flew all these hockey teams I
can't leave Victor coming from [ __ ]
towns like Winnipeg next you know
they're in Las Vegas for a three-day
weekend a today from arrive like three
days before the game so they're gambling
a show they might be catching a Zelda
bad you know circus Olay good web join
the cast yeah
next thing you know they come home with
super gonorrhea yeah
live the dream absinthe and well you
almost became the face of these Vegas
golden ice by accident you were you're a
big fan you're the first game right the
first game actually open a franchise
history yeah and then you're one of the
final games it's a Stanley Cup that's it
what's uh yeah I wants a few playoff
games final games I would say a handful
of games during the season I think
that's my that's my hockey team had a
blog oh I know I'm from Chicago but
that's a great team to adopt that's my
team
Vegas goes nice as much in our I was
actually telling Tony beforehand about
their pregame show physical actual Vegas
pregame show insane I took acid and went
to try to get to without any but that's
how you came the face of it were you
there
well no no but he texted me when he was
there is like I just got interviewed by
nan she'll calm on acid yeah
okay yes so I'm watching the game
between between pr1 impaired - like I
look for you first of all watching
hockey on acid amazing it was really
good it is amazing yeah but hockey was
especially good watching hockey on a
stage watching hockey on TV on acid was
great in between the periods
this guy is an isle with the camera crew
[Laughter]
so happy but happy I love that what the
[ __ ] I say that but alright dude he
pulled together if you look up that club
you pull it together yeah I was
panicking I mean it's a 30-second clip
he answered the question for six hours
but that's only 30 seconds me me no one
did ah too many words what by the way
why is your face melting what do you
like about the Stanley Cup man you know
the color
the water we might have to put a spud
with Mitch encounter I'll put it at 47
them you put at 47 bite of being really
hammer some spud Webb stories at the end
of spud is that his real name where's
that of nicknames and now just saving
Anthony is his first name if I recall
from my top scar that's kind of a
degrading name spud what a great name I
just think of potatoes potato a potato
web
the two you start you're from Philly
right yeah by starting Chicago you start
for the first time on stage at the did
the lines oh that was when you were
rapping right but flows Tom Draper
hey you got floss time trip you know we
all do rapping about sexual harassment
stuff like better what out there like I
wanna do second single do improv that's
what people do and yeah you know oh you
started with him yeah I did yeah you
took I gave them money how if I start on
improv I gave them money to classes and
I'm passing a fake ball around to a
house what if I'm like yeah maybe I
don't try something about attitude as
you can see I still have it were you a
starter or were you on the bench but I
know my role LeBron's right I just got
oh if I wanted to play tennis I would
play tennis but what happened next how
you quit this job
what happened huh York what and then you
did stand-up right yeah
then then I played golf that didn't work
really you play golf house the
individuals I do play golf actually what
I was going for you good I could play
what's your average score Jesus look at
you you ask you're so far as you ask
questions but like I bet no matter what
the answer is you would understand like
what you're looking for like never in my
life I don't know it's 200 could you
raise an average of 200 how often do you
play golf
I don't play at all oh I would be good
if I played but I don't trying to hit
you did you do any short form improv
games sure for yeah like by about zip
zop yeah exactly
Zoop spud Zac blue zip zap zop that zip
zap zop I feel like they warm up they
zip he's supposed to go there mm-hmm
yeah zip did you take him from you did
everything I'm up like we'd go around
these shows you always because him we're
always [ __ ] like his many shows you
can you know and like we do a show like
all right come on - how many sports and
so show them and like I can't come with
you my fingers just Anna but it's an
improv thing with a scoreboard up there
and like I just jump in a scene but then
handle still doing a set it was they had
improv so but they were given five it
was a midnight so yes exactly right yeah
background like him I can't give a [ __ ]
who's like what the format is it was
great you know yeah he was doing comedy
at [ __ ] acoustic guitar mic night he
didn't give a [ __ ] you know I like
stand-up comedy over mics but Mike's
poetry or music then that comedian so
they kind of yeah watch it like a show
sometimes like what the [ __ ] is going on
here sometimes they'd be like oh it's
something different that's a good point
you're not before sort of bad jaded
commenting during you know even if they
are performing a musician and I'm
writing during your set right I mean
it's literally comic relief for me cuz I
hate those acoustic
mic nights and if a comic went up there
I'd be like hell yeah the only time I
would ever go to one of those shows is
if I was like banging some broad that
plays the guitar
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's just come back said
[Music]
yeah Bobcat golfin told a story he
opened for nirvana for a while and they
were just [ __ ] co-main although we're
dying laughing in the background they
made him do because it made them laugh
like we just want to keep you because we
love we love when people throw stuff at
you like yeah that's a fun game the
great Supra that was that was on party
Legends right we had about that he like
came off the ceiling like naked with
wings on and should be more yeah that
was a story like he came they like he
was like tied to something and then he
came out the ceiling and then he was
like naked he was naked or some hours
closer I don't some some they tried to
go grandiose with the whole [ __ ] it's
not like he just came out there's like
oh yeah I'm Bobcat he's like they tried
to go crazy with it and then people are
just like what the [ __ ]
we're seeing they're violent he took my
fart man I was Howard Stern fart man I
was I don't know none of these
references are gonna make sense to
anyone did you have trouble in that when
you did that uh
Lauryn Hill a nice tour a little bit
though was that rough you're on the bill
Alfred out I was on the bill but it
still wasn't that and I that's not ideal
an ideal gig I think we were following
this reggae band
yeah between chronic sickness and yeah
chronic sickness ACC's got skills
Nan's a little manic
as Lily's yeah it was a tough game cuz
it was you know yeah outdoor
amphitheaters outdoors tougher the
indoor theater it would have still been
kind of tough but easier to manage I
think we did three three three or four
one of them yeah we did Miami outside DC
and Camden waterfront so yeah I suppose
the DC one was the best cuz I had a lot
of material about the first two shows
[Laughter]
they want to hear about how far the
venue was away from DC Oh what the [ __ ]
do feel ooh gotta [ __ ] away especially
for it for big crowds yeah you have to
go with bright jokes at least on opening
to get them all on the same yeah you
know it was funny too is like we were
doing like the we're doing like the
normal entrance he does for like his
head like yes we black out the lights
and play the video and stuff and it was
funny because it will toll the crowd
because they come back with the Bears
now he's about to go up and then here
comes Hannibal and they're like god
dammit
I drop the bait why is this man
a little bossy Alice where we would not
house I was talking with some folks
earlier about I reminded me before the
year of why I wrote it as soon L I got
asked to submit an audition tape to SNL
star to perform yes yeah but I didn't
love to see your five characters I
didn't take that opportunity very
seriously right this is 2008 yes what
that's not for me I'm gonna be a sketch
actor because at that point I hadn't
really done any acting at all fine being
a cast member that's a long shot I
didn't even consider I said it in just
to send it in you had more importantly
somebody we got a gun right but it might
be a it's a TV I think it was a DVD
because it's 2008 so burn to the DV tape
label on the top of it to dated
holy [ __ ] phone number probably took
seven hours burn it onto a goddamn DVD
[ __ ] hotmail email address I did stand
up a little bit my impression mm-hmm was
spud Webb Chris Rock
doing an impression of Jerry's can you
still do it I'm all dear
why do people deal with this it would go
a little something like this as like a
lady's impressions what if maro and
Jerry saddles having dinner like this
rock doing Seinfeld that's a solid bit
solid and is I like it
five minutes stand-up that character
what else you do three more that's all
you keep put on there yeah that's
hilarious and after yeah they still give
you a job a year later are you stay in
the back that's amazing I thought I was
blackballed after that that tapes I'm so
bad
[Music]
but that wasn't that was a remake of an
a song CJ if you're willing to go to
this place with us we like to revisit
the fight party at Tony turns out in a
very dark place let's just address let's
address that night you're in a bark
place
I've finally go to that place that story
that night encapsulated me I believe the
highest of highs the darkest of the dark
dark is the lows and low all within the
north in about 40 seconds span really oh
yeah because you dis one is bad why do
you think I was like I just blinked yeah
I just went against a hit I think wasn't
Holly home it was a woman's ever in
there yeah and I picked the underdog I
think was Holly home yeah she knocked
out Rousey right I don't know that
wasn't around I wasn't around I wasn't
the Rousey one that was I think that was
Holly Holmes set that's the fight after
Holly Holm maybe lost and she was a big
honored oh it was a big underdog yeah
huge I don't play let's not forget the
the only good part that happened to me
that night that was me winning yeah yeah
okay oh yeah you did great that night
thank you you know at Toni trims mm a
viewing party mm a party Saturday night
yeah and it was fun I came in hot came
in late for a couple shows what a handle
of smirnoff not first time I've done
that yeah stragglers with me I came in
to an MMA poor Yugi I come into it MMA
viewing part Hasen Tony's got or during
a fight you know you either some
like-minded loud
Gaming fight night kind of people like
when I got in there I realized it was
that no one was nowhere close to my
level of like oh well is that socially
and feeling you know how portraying
myself right did I have a bottle in my
hand I mean you guys could yeah you
definitely film the details more than
that you came with a bottle of Smirnoff
you're gonna bring something to the
party yeah but it was funny because
nobody touched the Smirnoff it was your
Smirnoff your herbal vacuum yeah right
your smear now I thought I'm gonna find
out which I was yeah and you guys were
there obviously I still have that bottle
of Smirnoff by the way but going but I
was definitely more laid-back hipsters
seen their the fight the fight wasn't
coming through did we have to yeah that
that's it [ __ ] with a periscope it
remember yeah little bit we got his back
feels like periscopes yeah we got a big
I called them and I got it we got it
back but yeah and yeah we panic for a
little bit cuz it was like right right
McGregor or was it during like the first
round I don't know maybe McGregor was
the headliner but I won the fight before
yeah it was a big lose more than five to
one dawg
mm-hmm and then God forbid I win a bet
like that and people don't tell me I'm
all night I mean I told you that's all
night yeah I told him well why did you
not better easy money
they're giving away money I don't see
why you didn't take it hand will hates
free money everybody it's funny I always
thought he's a smart person but
apparently there's a lot of that I was I
was uh I was asking for it basically
karma wise you know I so I came in hot I
was I was I was definitely uh easily but
top five loudest there one through five
you know and then was it after shoes
after after the fight the last fights
McGregor fight I celebrated let's get to
the point you can fill in the details
wife yeah I I Swan diving I don't see it
you saw it I heard it yeah I heard it I
was like I did a gymnastic dismount if
you will like we were talking about
earlier what was complete fell face
forward into the part into it was a
tight part was pretty packed you know
yeah so it seemed for half a second you
thought I was joking with the fall
because it will
there was no stumbles it was like I
don't have a nice trip over or something
or did you just just oh I think I blamed
your dog for a while because your dog
was he was he was hitting the shins for
a while no he gets don't blame Roxy she
didn't do nothing I bunt cowboy down
below that [ __ ] oh yeah he got
attacked by my neighbor's dog yeah
cowboy [ __ ] worst yeah I'm sure he
doesn't
cowboy what do we do
he's bite be like okay well the dog came
straight at cuz cuz see given a siege a
ride home after we did that little tour
and he was a fresh road trip from Iowa
the three of us he's standing in the
yard so I go cuz they watch rocks when
I'm out of town so I went to go grab
rocks she was so she comes out excited
and she's jumping up and then cowboy
comes out and he's coming at me but then
he sees CJ and CJ's got you know CJ's
got his little bowling bag looking
[ __ ] I'm at the end of the driveway
yeah luggage carrier thing and then
cowboy looks over at CJ and just I don't
know what happened he just snaps and he
just starts going at CJ's such that just
starts barking at him like oh [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] so he started he puts his
little luggage thing in front of him and
he's just kind of like I'm using as a
shield like Captain America on my
[ __ ] waving at him and it was a dog
get your dog and and [ __ ] cowboy kind
of Jeju to me dude he didn't give me a
[ __ ] nice Barry Sanders and like got
behind me got bit him right in the ass
like Coppertone baby style the owner
that prick was even moving he was just
sitting on the porch the cowboy hugging
a person cowboy cowboy does it do that
understand that's right he's my guy he's
they and Cowboys a sweet dog there sure
is a guy something snapped in them that
day I don't know what how would I do
that cowboy way I don't know why Cowboys
Mike I know why Cowboys yes don't make
excuses
right that's like when people make
excuses for the serial killers he was
he's super mild-mannered he was so quiet
I can't believe I just can't believe it
happened I never would have suspected I
know what cowboy did it could you give
it orders I didn't use like he
understands human language like he
doesn't he can't just understand human
conversation you have to give more than
his orders there's anyway so I fall
pretty hard and I was on that ground for
her solid like 20 seconds you fall on
your face that went straight forward
face you guys didn't like anyone fill in
some details you guys definitely know I
don't wanna fall itself you know people
fall right but yeah he was a stay down
no you just mentally you did well it was
highly embarrassing I was already in an
uncomfortable situation where I only
knew basically you - yeah and like it
was all your friends whatever like it
you know whatever like Logan Square
whatever whatever hipster area and I
don't know I didn't really know anybody
so I was already nervous and I was
already being too loud I was kind of not
conscious of it obviously but yeah I
felt like somebody did it not one guy
ripped you yeah yeah that was I mean
complain new doesn't know interrupt me I
was saying that like you you kept saying
you were talking like someone was out to
get you of course let it go you're sort
of God nice almost trying to kill me
here's the thing I go with it I'm not
gonna back I'm not gonna back up a be
wrong and I'm wrong say you know like
like I don't trust your friend's tone I
think something I think they're trying
to kill me
we want you to bar afterwards you know
right I still wanna let it go
yeah you can
what are we doing and who is this guy
right what are we looking for well did
you see anything you know tapes you have
security cameras here I know your
computer's got a camera on it was that
running what's your password I swear to
god somebody somebody trapped me I swear
to God
that's sort of God I don't just fall
like that yeah yeah I will not let it go
so I that becomes a much bigger
situation kinda like Watergate to cover
up as much worse than a crime yeah I
mean right now yeah it's a paranoid
tactic destroy someone there didn't
forgot I fall so if everyone remembers
the my reminder they're like oh that's a
guy wouldn't shut up about falling yeah
you know wait was this it's a risky
strategy was there you're gonna 10
t-shirts based because you're branding
of it so memorable and then you had
imaginary beef afterwards relentless
branding yeah absolutely
how's my defense beautiful you released
a album this year right I did yeah
called what am i complaining about it
was a sarcastic title then I kind of
didn't become sarcastic and then yeah
you can find it on CJ's solving comedy
comm I wanna date some whatnot yeah on
the streaming platforms Amazon and
iTunes that's all it is and all in a
trend the track titles aren't are all
just driving tips tonight I figure
people listen to cars anyway so it's
like don't text and drive we'll come on
track six and okay there's like 24
different driving tips on what still
yield no no come on basic Oh 24 I feel
like you got a DUI hit some lists I
don't look some up I guess keep your
eyes on the road
don't burn right
in front of a bus tied and told no it's
not that it's kind of like most yeah
most accidents are happened don't like
getting on a road rage a lot of that to
like everyone who'd cut you off it's not
in a personal attack you know yeah that
kind of thing leasing why do I bring
this up I was supposed to be I throw one
off line here we go
figures distraction oh I'm playing it be
assertive behind the wheel but not
aggressive don't speed it's better to
arrive late than never at all and
there's and these titles have absolutely
nothing to do it did with the bits huh
no absolutely not
shrink your emotional territory whoa
it's a nice one they made a mistake give
them a break this is that song and some
bars on that one take a deep breath
yeah lobbies are long so I can't if I
click them on I'll play the track yes on
the way what am i complaining about yeah
and I would love to purchase if I can to
get on the website that audition of you
know sorry love Chris rights of that and
you know what I wouldn't mind getting to
producing the business of the I smell
beef podcast drop out so yeah I'll pick
up those scraps yeah you know it's gonna
be a hit and you're gonna regret not
taking this beautiful opportunity right
okay I don't support you guys
prove me wrong you know what aren't you
glad you aren't on a morning radio
because if we were I would have said so
what are you complaining about now CJ
yes
[Music]
whatever I could play the water what's a
day there's a newspaper what are you
doing playing about your megaphone
you're putting into a mic maybe that
your energy at 5:30 in the morning
complaining about your energy all this
dumb sound effects you keep playing if
you could in if you could pick up a
skill an attainable skill I think my
backflip is attainable attainable skill
like what would you if you start up in
the next couple of weeks
what would you work on man you think you
do a backflip in two weeks
no I'm saying what would you do in two
weeks like to get started up cuz I'm not
gonna start tomorrow right if I start on
my backflip journey I'm not gonna get
right into it
uh-huh but in next two weeks I will Oh
give yourself ramp up time you know but
you got it that's like research time
yeah texts friends hype you up yeah well
I was telling Tony trim before the show
actually I guess willpower would be a
thing because of we're both smoking and
I was telling him I got this book Alan
Carr's easy way to quit smoking which
supposed to be a legendary book that
everyone loves and they encourage you to
smoke while you read the book like you
can smoke all the way through to read
the book you know terrible book just
smoking the crack well it's just not
scare you because smokers well you got
to quit right now I will [ __ ] I'm not
gonna read you know
so you're reading and it goes along but
now I'm getting to the part the last
third of it where you have to apply
yourself like yeah the application I'm
actually quitting it so I'm really
taking my time with it I'm that one page
of time like licking it like okay
half a page today I page tomorrow some
like watching horrible movies on flights
and [ __ ] look anything to avoid
finishing this book we're off to start
quitting smoking so I'm thinking two
weeks is a good time period to actually
wait on analytical willpower finishing
I'm being motivated to finish a
motivational book I don't know you got a
back flip back from to me so beyond the
realm I want you I came to think of any
but quitting smoking that's a solid man
yeah but you got a UH what you gonna
replace it with okay we net heroin yeah
sure
no but like chewing sticks like baggy
toothpick guys affiliation yeah I don't
know if you they need that thing that's
all myth yeah maybe what you want
plastic straws and everyone's throwing
them away not throw them away now these
are being outlawed you could do these
without nicotine in them but they're
vape yeah it's funny like when the
electronic cigarette vape first came out
I got someone to help they may be to
help me quit smoking you know like Doody
fixation whatever that's where I thought
it was for but then after like two weeks
like Billy Zane does a commercial on an
office um became like the look of a
douchebag if you've a day everyone look
down upon it like a brother normal in
the fame like sorry I'm trying to live
you know but yeah guys methadone there's
work there's a yeah there's a stigma of
like douche bag yeah but it's like [ __ ]
it's cut my smoking down significantly
that's what I mean but it's socially so
unacceptable
I like the vape on you smoke testify it
tastes great fire some you know berries
mixed berry flavors
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this cousin took Japanese like gameshow
feel good I love it
I'm saying it's great if you want do you
want a random stop smoking [ __ ]
texts oh I say I'll send them
I'll send texts okay and I'll give you a
limber up text or something you yeah
bachelor like hey have you been
practicing all right lumber up what else
sorry Talia maybe set some calendar
reminders yeah phone okay hey don't
smoke right at one of those today Lee
I've been doing that for writing and
other stuff just motivate yourself to
write so motivate yourself to write or
just do stuff and sometimes still don't
write but I remember there is there it's
so at the very least he's going out
[Laughter]
thanks for coming on a song yes Thank
You CJ we love you man
seven more and I catch both CJ Sullivan
calm County girl she just on family sees
a Sullivan comedy calm
[Music]
[Music]